you are watching the very first episode
of functional filmmaking after months
and months it's finally out now the rest
of the series you can find on corridor
digital.com but for now enjoy this first
spin here on youtube
camera technology has fascinated me for
as long as i can remember the power to
visually capture and replicate a moment
in time would be considered magic a few
hundred years ago and here we are now
trying to keep our cats in focus as they
chase after a laser one of the things
that excites me most about cameras is
how quickly they are changing whereas
most century-old inventions have settled
into their ideal form cameras are
receiving incredible redefining
developments every year this presents a
never-ending stream of creative
opportunity but it can also feel like a
gargantuan chore trying to stay on top
of all this tech that's why i'm going to
teach you how to be a functional
filmmaker with any camera
[Music]
since starting in the year 2000 shooting
videos with sam on an old canon gl1 i've
had the opportunity to work with
hundreds of different imaging devices
this class will be an insight into the
experiences and core philosophies that i
have learned from my video journey all
to help you get the best from any camera
let's get one thing out there you can
get a great emotionally compelling image
from any camera any camera however if
you have a specific look in mind not
every camera will be appropriate it is
important to let your tools talk to you
and influence your vision i want to free
you from a budget limited mindset and
make you a better filmmaker with the
tools you have easy access to the main
topics on your journey to camera mastery
that we will cover are how to identify
and exploit the strengths of your camera
what makes a good image the philosophy
is driving camera tech that every
cinematographer should know and finally
how to achieve a good final image
independently of color science or color
grading all right so there are hundreds
of different cameras out there and
different cameras are good at different
things to get the best from your camera
you must play to its strengths and tune
your creative approach to take advantage
of what you have there's no such thing
as the perfect camera but there is the
right tool for the right job thankfully
as a creative you get to determine what
type of job you're doing the best
artists work cooperatively with their
tools not in conflict with them
no this isn't an ad i just want to tell
you why functional filmmaking is so cool
first of all we have four more exclusive
episodes coming out on corridor
digital.com and this entire show was
made possible through the financial
support of our website subscribers no
ads no third parties nothing like that
and that's what makes corridor
digital.com so special
sam
no i i got this man don't take that
no no no that's that's so they know that
the timer
okay hold on
sam what are you shush
golly
all right so how do you identify the
strengths of your camera before we can
go any further we need to establish our
goal we're trying to make a good image
but what makes a good image for this
class i'm going to define good as
emotionally compelling images can serve
a lot of different purposes it's not to
say that visual beauty isn't important
but the thing we want most is for our
image to create an emotional response
it's the exact same philosophy that a
composer would apply when writing their
music for the score of a film how do we
make emotionally compelling images well
we do that through combining three
techniques
presenting story information in a shot
movement
and visual beauty
all right so let's start with the first
step there's a very simple and easy
trick i use to test if a shot is
conveying the story correctly here's how
it works first verbally define
exactly what the single shot is going to
communicate to the audience do this in a
single sentence for example sam opens
the door to the pitch black room and
turns on the lights revealing an alien
body
if we are to communicate this in one
shot we need to see a pitch black space
we need to see sam open a door to that
pitch black space we need to see him
perform the action of turning on a light
and once the light comes on we need to
see the alien body
in that order so now try to imagine a
single shot that can convey all of that
visualize how it plays in your mind
where's the camera where is sam how do
you show the dark room and reveal the
alien there's no wrong answer
yet
[Music]
all right go ahead and shut the door and
did you see the actions open the door
reach over turn on the light see the
body
so we're going to cut the light down
kill those guys that guy would be back
there so what do you think is best for
the episode cause i could i can shoot
this on my phone it'll look fine a
successful take on the iphone and do a
successful take on that
yeah the hdr recording format makes the
iphone look really nice the shot still
takes i'm going to shoot the shot both
on the red and my phone just kind of
show you can get something great with
both options thank you this is a shot
that's very story based and i think is a
great example because it can be
good on any camera the shot itself just
has to be good and it'll read great on
any camera
sam opens the door to the pitch black
room and turns on the lights revealing
an alien body
oh my god all right so now how do we
know if your concept of the shot will
work that comes down to the next step
pull out a stopwatch and say out loud
the information you are communicating
the sentence that we came up with and
time how long it takes to say it boop
sam opens the door to the pitch black
room and turns on the lights revealing
an alien body boop all right if the time
it takes you to say the sentence is
faster than the shot it's a sign that
your shot is paced too slowly or that
you're adding information that is
unnecessary the timing lines up and your
shot visually communicates your sentence
well congratulations your shot is
presenting information for the story and
it's paced perfectly now there's a key
difference between photography and
cinematography any guesses as to what
that might be
movement
that's right our pictures move they're
called movies
and if we didn't utilize movement in our
cinematography then we are hobbling our
ability to make compelling imagery there
are three main types of movement and a
compelling shot generally includes at
least one of them first we have a moving
camera moving camera implies perspective
and in doing so it creates story hold
your camera in your hands use a gimbal
fly a drone bring your voice to life
through your moving perspective second
kind of movement a moving subject let
your subject shift positions in the
frame moving from point a to point b and
not just occupying one spot this gives
the subject life and intention and the
third type of movement is a moving
environment think snow falling or leaves
moving in the wind or even looking at a
car window as the world goes by this
makes the space come to life so movement
by its nature communicates new
information as time progresses and this
is the fundamental tool for creating a
story how you use movement in your shot
is crucial and even the worst video
cameras still capture movement in pretty
much the exact same way as an expensive
camera that's it different cameras move
in different ways and the type of
movement you do with your footage is a
vibe the movement in our world's longest
lightsaber video is very different from
the movement and shadow of mordor and
they both speak to the story one being
reality captured on a phone with some
friends
the other being a cinematic entry into
the lord of the rings universe so at the
end of the day every camera provides you
an opportunity for interesting movement
and taking advantage of interesting
movement will make your footage look
great this finally brings us to the last
part of creating an emotionally
compelling image this step is often
prioritized first in many people's minds
though i often find it to be the least
important of the three
visual beauty
now discussing cinematography tips to
get a beautiful image is something that
could cover a whole season's worth of
functional filmmaking videos but that's
not my goal here i'm striving to teach
you how to get the best out of any
camera so with that said let's give an
overview on visual beauty beauty is
generally defined by what the eye is
instinctually wired to see such as
bright objects colors movement human
faces bodies hands knowing this build
your image to focus our attention on
what matters
lighting and angles are your key tools
for constructing a composition and how
your camera captures light lines
contrast and color will greatly
influence this a shot that utilizes
those four elements should be
aesthetically strong regardless of the
camera you're using so let's talk about
them first off we have light now because
this is not a lighting class i'll be
saying criminally few words on the power
of light our brains need directional
light to understand the form of objects
in the three-dimensional shape and when
it comes to getting the best out of any
camera should know that you need to be
hitting almost everything in your scene
with some light even dark areas will
benefit from having a couple of photons
bouncing around to your camera be it a
phone gopro dslr whatever
light equals data if you want detail
your camera needs data and that means
light even shadows have detail so get
some photons up in your scene all right
lines lines guide the eye and your
vision instinctually travels along them
like a water slide our eyes are
hardwired to see lines in the world
around us and our brains turn those
lines into forms and those forms into
symbols and the symbols and information
lines are everywhere and you will
manipulate them through lighting angles
and your set design use them to point us
at things that are important use them to
focus our attention there's a reason why
the edge light is one of the most
powerful lighting tricks to make an
image look pretty and captivating
contrast is the next tool you have in
your arsenal how do you separate
foreground and background how do you
make something seem bright or dark
how do you perceive form and shape well
the answer lies in contrast for you to
know that something is bright you need
to see something that's dark as a point
of reference if you want to bring
attention to an element or an idea in
your frame adding something there to
contrast against it will do the job
color is the final tool we have in our
arsenal color brings to mind certain
emotions and they can highlight our
attention through contrast as well now
oftentimes movies that we think are
colorful are very frequently just
monochromatic but the whole image is
tinted a certain color to inspire an
emotion keep in mind that while you can
get as stylized as you want with your
colors people often prefer to see skin
tones as they naturally are which is a
basic orangish hue hey guys it's me
again back for another ad break uh this
time i want to tell you about the green
light feature on quarterdigital.com it
allows you to take your subscription
dollars and put them into projects you
want to see us make we already did phase
one that's what functional filmmaking is
all about we've got crew cuts we've got
son of a dungeon local zero we also just
introduced phase two of green light
which has a bunch of new awesome
projects that we want to get in
production now including corridor live
corridor forums new bones for peter
jake's dream project ah don't do
my dream project
you just he just ruined my dream project
now that we've defined what makes a good
image how do we get that from any camera
well by understanding the strengths of
our particular camera a good craftsman
lets their tools influence their work so
how do we get your camera to influence
your image well first put the camera in
your hands even if it's just a phone
think back to how we define what makes
an emotionally compelling image
information movement and visual beauty
and the different ways we can achieve
that so what aspects of an emotionally
compelling image can your camera easily
capture bone it's easy to get unique
angles with you have strength through
composition a gopro is easy to get
movement with so you have strength and
movement dslr gives you great separation
through focus so you have strength and
contrast the red gives you a very high
fidelity image so you have strength
through lighting so just examples but
every camera opens up certain
opportunities to truly get the best from
your camera you need to think about what
it is that makes your camera unique and
then creatively integrate that strength
into your filmmaking every camera is
associated with a vibe or a genre phones
are associated with viral videos dslrs
are associated with independent
filmmaking and vlogging gopros are
associated with action sports if you're
stuck using a certain camera consider
tweaking your story to play towards the
genre your camera is associated with if
i had to shoot a zombie movie on the
gopro
well i would direct it with a frenetic
energy that complements the action
sports genre that gopros are known for
whereas if i had to shoot down a red i
would make this piece much more moodier
and darker and try to go for something
tension-filled
[Music]
now if you tried to shoot the moody and
dark version of the zombie movie on a
gopro
well your camera strengths would not
really support the elements you need to
capture that appropriate emotion this
isn't to say it's impossible to shoot
something cinematic on the gopro but you
will have to work harder you have to be
extremely more creative to pull it off
successfully
instead if you just embrace your
camera's strengths and use your
creativity to turn those strikes into
unique compelling imagery only made
possible by your camera you will wow
people regardless of the strengths of
your camera we still want to achieve
visual beauty at some point and that
requires understanding the technical
philosophies driving digital image
capture so here are the seven enemies
that you will battle when trying to
capture a technically clean digital
image enemy number one clipped
highlights at a certain point of
brightness a part of your image will
become white any difference in tonality
that may have existed in this bright
part becomes lost and any attempt to
color grade that exposure down just
gives you gray yuck all right enemy two
noisy grainy shadows
similar to clipped highlights but on the
opposite end of the tonality scale at a
certain point of darkness any attempt to
color grade your footage up in exposure
just reveals noise and no shadow detail
yuck enemy three compression many
cameras are limited to the amount of
data they can write per frame if you
have a lot of high detailed elements in
your shot that are quickly changing on a
frame by frame basis
camera will have to blur these details
in order to fit them all into its memory
budget yuck four sharpening many cameras
have a fake sharpen effect where dark
edges are added to bright points in
order to make the details pop by
bringing out some local contrast when
pushed too far what you end up with are
white and black lines surrounding all of
your details
yuck enemy five over saturated colors
similar to clipped highlights but with
color once again you lose any sense of
tonality and the color becomes one flat
wash
yuck
number six inaccurate colors because
lights come in a lot of different hues
cameras have to calibrate to what they
think a neutral white point is in order
to correctly represent colors relative
to each other many times your camera
guesses wrong why is everybody blue
yuck enemy number seven
unintentional camera shake imagine
trying to look at a painting in a museum
but the pain just randomly shifts a few
feet in every direction yuck so more
expensive cameras have more tolerance
when it comes to these pesky problems
but they don't eliminate them that's
where your skillful hand as an artist
comes in now in order to clarify how
this all works i want to create an
analogy
here we have a grid of buckets
each bucket is a photosite on your
sensor and water is going to represent
our light
this is my light
when a water droplet lands in a bucket
it's like a photon hitting your camera
sensor now here's where the universe
conspires against us and our cameras the
universe is filled with random particles
of energy flying around
sorry
these energy particles affect your
camera's sensor to represent this we are
going to have it lightly rain over these
buckets
so now these buckets are out in the rain
slowly filling up with water even though
we haven't even shined any light on them
yet so now i'll turn on my light which
is represented by this hose and shine it
on the camera sensors
[Applause]
now we can measure the amount of water
in the buckets to see how much light has
hit them but we need to account for the
rain looking at the buckets before we
shine a light at them we can see that
there is about an inch of rain water so
anything over that is the light that
we've added
this is a representation of
signal-to-noise ratio our hose of light
is the signal and the rain is the noise
if a bucket is filled up with seven
inches of water and the rain averaged
one inch then it's easy to get a
confident measurement of the amount of
light the bucket actually absorbed but
if only a few drops of our water ended
up in the bucket well we're gonna have a
really hard time telling the difference
between our signal from the hose and the
noise which is the rain so the same
thing applies to real cameras there's
only a little bit of light in the room
your camera is going to have a very hard
time distinguishing between what's your
signal the light and what's the random
energy noise therefore if you want to
get a good image with your camera you
need to give your scene enough light
that you are above the signal-to-noise
ratio better cameras have better
signal-to-noise ratios and require less
light to get a clear image
experiment with your camera do some
tests and learn what its signal to noise
capabilities are let that inform how
much light you need for your scene now
let's say you decide to make sure you
have no issues with flight so you decide
to blast your scene with light
[Music]
[Applause]
i've i lit your scene great now you've
created another problem your buckets are
full you can't tell if you dumped one
gallon or 10 gallons of water on your
buckets because at a certain point your
bucket can't fill up anymore
this is an analogy for highlight
clipping also referred to as blowing out
your whites now this is one of your
greatest enemies when it comes to
shooting digitally and it's a challenge
because you need to bring enough light
into your scene to rise above that noise
floor but not so much light as to fill
up your bucket all the way and clip the
brightest parts of your image the amount
of water that we can measure between our
noise floor and when the bucket is full
is referred to as our dynamic range if
we replace our buckets with tiny little
cups we certainly find ourselves with a
very difficult challenge
[Applause]
i broke my camera the cups fill up
almost instantly if we shine light at
them but too little light and we can't
tell the difference from noise so cheap
cameras basically have the equivalent of
cups whereas expensive cameras have the
equivalent of buckets taller buckets
have more dynamic range skinny buckets
have better signal-to-noise ratios the
taller and skinnier the bucket the
better and often more expensive the
sensor is in order to get the best image
out of your sensor you need to control
the amount of light in your scene to
keep it within your dynamic range
this singular concept when mastered will
be one of the most powerful skills you
can have to get a great image out of
your camera so we have yet to talk about
any adjustments you can do to your image
on the computer you know after you've
picked up any camera you've shot your
video you're almost ready to export it
and share with the world
let's just talk about color grading for
a minute it's an extremely powerful tool
to have in your pocket and one of the
key ingredients to getting a great
compelling image the problem is
there are hundreds of different color
profiles for hundreds of different
cameras and many different color
sciences for the countless different
displays and monitors out there
so in color grading wouldn't it be nice
if there was just a single universal
method that you could use as a guideline
to dial in your image well there is it's
called the zone system and it was
invented by the renowned landscape
photographer ansel adams this is the
method that i use to guide my color
grading no matter what camera i'm using
or what screen i'm working on thankfully
the zone system is super simple and easy
to use here's how it works imagine a
gradient from black to white now divide
that gradient into 11 steps with black
being your first step also known as zone
zero and then each subsequent brighter
step increasing evenly until you reach
white on your 11th step aka zone 10. so
now you have 11 zones that represent
different tonality ranges zone 0 is pure
black zone 5 is a middle gray zone 10 is
pure white no matter what display you're
using or what color science you're using
you can imagine any image on any screen
being broken down into these zones now
ansel adams came up with a guide as to
what kind of elements should fall into
each zone for example well-lit caucasian
skin should sit in zone six or around
sixty percent of your peak brightness
shaded leaves should sit around zone
four about forty percent of your peak
brightness and a clear north sky should
sit right in the middle at zone 5. now
there are different tools one can use to
measure this as well you can look at a
waveform to see where the brightness
sits for different parts of your image
or you can even use an eyedropper to
measure the brightness of a single pixel
you can even imagine a histogram being
divided into 11 parts to see where the
tones of your image fall if you're
fortunate enough to access these tools
in your camera directly while recording
i highly recommend utilizing them and
this will let you apply the zone system
before you even get to color grading the
likelihood of your image looking great
and compelling will almost appear
effortless if you follow these
guidelines for every shot you'll end up
with a very consistent look and the
tones will follow a well-defined system
that the human eye genuinely finds
pleasing effectively we're just applying
our color science of our eye the main
color science that we need to keep in
mind so these are the driving
philosophies and techniques that i apply
to my camerawork regardless of the type
of camera that i'm holding in my hand
these philosophies will give you a
strong first step to capturing a
beautiful image and will only set you up
for more rewards should you invest the
time to learn the technical specifics of
your camera system
as you use different cameras throughout
your life you'll be armed with a great
cornerstone for your knowledge letting
you make emotionally compelling great
images with any camera thank you for
watching my functional filmmaking
episode and thank you everyone who put
their producer points into green
lighting this series and subscribed on
our website
i hope you enjoy more of the wonderful
knowledge the rest of the corridor team
has to share with you
ah what a tough day there's no parking
outside and well let's just hope there's
nothing else that goes wrong in my life
today
[Music]
oh
oh my god
is that an alien body
okay i'm gonna try to make this quick
because i think sam's getting the chops
for it but anyways there's no time like
right now to sign up for corridor
digital.com okay we've got four new
features on the green light page we've
got peter's smoosh for us today that's
coming out right now available for
download we did a makeover the entire
site that's desktop ios android we got
smart apps coming we got better
compression than youtube way better we
have a better community you get 15 off
all merch all the time and of course you
get every video early and with no ads i
mean there's really nothing like it i
gotta get out of this
[Laughter]
you